9 stands about 230 feet tall which is
greater than the wingspan of a 747
aircraft now the bottom two-thirds of
the vehicle is a brand new first stage
and its job is to accelerate the entire
vehicle through the Earth's atmosphere
up to the edge of space now unlike our
first GPS 3 mission from December and
2018 we will be attempting to recover
the first stage on our drone ship named
just read the instructions and it's
currently stationed about 350 nautical
miles off the east coast of Florida we
worked with our customer following our
earlier GPS 3 mission to ensure that we
maintained more than enough performance
margin for both the primary mission and
a chance at recovery today on that first
stage now above the first stage is the
second stage and about two and a half
minutes into flight it will separate
from the first stage then it'll ignite
it's single Merlin vacuum engine to
carry the GPS 3 satellite into a highly
elliptical orbit the apogee or the
highest point of that orbit will
ultimately end up at about 20,000
kilometers above the Earth's surface at
which point the satellite will then
separate and then perform some burns to
enter into a circular medium Earth orbit
about 20,000 200 kilometers above the
earth you'll also notice that the second
stage fuel tank is painted gray today
and that's so we absorb a little more
heat from the Sun while we're not
eclipsed by the earth that helps the
fuel tank stay at the proper temperature
for today's mission when we go into the
Earth's shadow now at the very top of
the rocket is the payload fairing the
GPS 3 satellite is currently enclosed
inside of it and it's 17 feet in
diameter it protects the satellite from
aerodynamic heating loads and
contamination during the ascent portion
of the mission but once we reach the
vacuum of space
well jettison those fairing halves back
to Earth while the second stage
continues to take the satellite to orbit
the fairing halves that we're using
today are brand new and we will be
attempting to recover them using our
recovery ships mystery and mischeif
however we aren't planning a catch
attempt today and instead we'll scoop
these out of the water later on this
evening
now finally next to the rocket is that
large truss structure that we refer to
as the transporter erector or te the te
rolls Falcon 9 out to the launch pad
raises it to the vertical launch
position and also routes power fluids
and communication to both
rocket and satellite good afternoon I'm
John this burger Falcon 9 principle
integration engineer here at SpaceX
we're coming up on nine and a half
minutes to launch and to get to this
point we were all Falcon nine out to the
pad Sunday night about 41 hours before
launch
we went vertical on the pad at roughly
10 a.m. local time yesterday the chief
engineer held his technical pole at
t-minus 1 hours and the launch director
held a propellant load and launch
go/no-go pole at t-minus 38 minutes the
vehicle is healthy we are currently
working no issues now if we do have to
call a hold on today's launch we have a
backup opportunity tomorrow at 351
Eastern Time in the afternoon that's
about four minutes earlier than today's
opening of the window now right now
we're targeting the end of the window
just after 1610 Eastern time for liftoff
now after the go no-go poles Falcon 9
has been loading propellants began at
t-minus 35 minutes we began with field
going into both the first and second
stage oxidizer into the first stage for
fuel we use a refined form of kerosene
known as rp1 active propellant grade one
our oxidizer is a super chilled liquid
oxygen and we call that LOX now
currently the second stage that you can
see outlined with that gray paint that
Shiva mentioned that fuel is completely
loaded we're still loading feel on the
first stage
that'll go until t-minus six minutes and
as you can see from the plume streaming
off of the first and second stage LOX
tanks we are continuing to load liquid
oxygen on to both of those stages right
now we're also loading helium gas
onboard storage vessels on the first and
second stage the Falcon nine uses helium
gas is a pressure int in the fuel and
the LOX tanks as the merlin engine pumps
pull our p1 and walks out of the tanks
we have to fill the empty volume what we
call ollege with helium that is heated
by the engine heating the helium helps
expand it to fill the tanks now at
t-minus seven minutes coming up here
engine chill will begin will hear that
call out
is where we allow a small amount of the
super chilled liquid oxygen to flow past
the turbopump inlets that cools them
down to avoid thermal shocks when we
light the merlin engines at t-minus two
seconds finally you can see to the left
of the rocket is the transport director
or what we also called a strong back
that will retract away from the rocket
about two degrees at t-minus four
minutes that gives the necessary
clearance for Falcon nine to begin the
liftoff sequence now top of Falcon nine
we have the spacecraft the spacecraft
team has transitioned the GPS satellite
to internal battery power that happened
at t-minus 15 minutes they're working no
issues and there are no further actions
required to the satellite before launch
we're launching out of the eastern range
and currently the range is go they're
ready to support the air and the sea
space is clear around us they've also
been launching the balloons for us to
help get the weather the weather from
clouds lightning electric fields right
now is go what we've been watching is
the upper altitude winds the gradient
but from one altitude to the other has
been borderline where we might exceed
the low capability of Falcon 9
we are currently go we will get one last
weather balloon piece of data coming up
here in a couple of minutes but right
now all systems continue to be go for a
liftoff just after 4:00 10 p.m. Eastern
Time now as we mentioned earlier today's
mission is for the United States space
force and we're launching the GPS three
space vehicle number three as our
payload now we'll hear from Lieutenant
Colonel Margaret Sullivan materiel
leader of the GPS three space vehicles
and Tonya Lodwick acting vice president
of navigation systems at Lockheed Martin
to learn more about today's satellite
[Music]
we use GPS every day today everyone has
GPS technology in their pockets 25 years
of space-based position navigation and
timing supporting the entire world
GPS touches the lives of everyday people
all the time it's changed the way we
work it's changed the way we play with
over four billion users worldwide we're
already preparing for the next
generation of GPS satellites with our
GPS three follow-on contract and we're
inserting greater technology for greater
capability
[Music]
so brand-new United States space sports
owns this premier asset and provides
this position navigation and hiding
service to everyone and for all
personnel to condemn it we have a update
from GNC as for me as we have a good
weather bullets proceeding on with the
countdown keep my apartment spy second
second today's GPS three space vehicle
three mission is dedicated by the space
force to the memory of Colonel Thomas
Falzarano
and we will hear directly from general
Raymond and others who knew and work
with him just before we enter our first
Coast phase later on in the broadcast
now we're currently just inside four
minutes from liftoff we did get the good
news just a moment ago that the latest
weather balloon is go for launch so
we're going to continue to countdown
we've begun retracting the transporter
erector strong back away from your
Falcon nine you can see it on your
screen moves back a couple of degrees to
get us ready for liftoff now the Falcon
9 is now moving into the final stages of
the countdown the vehicle remains in
good health
Theo loading is complete on both the
first and second stages liquid oxygen
loading will wrap up shortly on the
first stage and will complete at t-minus
two minutes on the second stage if one
minute before liftoff you'll hear the
announcement that Falcon 9 isn't start
up that means the Rockets own internal
computers on first and second stage or
are controlling the launch countdown the
GPS three space vehicle continues to be
go the Falcon 9 team is tracking no
issues on the rocket the weather has
turned green for us here in the last
minutes and the range continues to be
green for launch now again as a reminder
if we don't launch today we have a
backup opportunity at 3:51 p.m. Eastern
Time tomorrow
first station our code complete launch
director has just called out that the
first stage locks load is complete we're
now loading just liquid oxygen on the
second stage approximately half a minute
block loading should complete on stage
two t-minus two minutes that
announcement tells us that that chi'lan
that we began at t-minus seven minutes
has lasted long enough and we are good
for the ignition sequence on the merlin
engines coming over a minute and 40
seconds
now coming up in the background you can
see some white plumes coming off of the
strong bank over 30 there's a nice view
we have completed loading the second
stage we're now draining the liquid
oxygen out of the plumbing that goes up
that structure alongside the rocket and
as we vent off the gas you get that nice
long plume you see there where that
humid Florida air meets the ultra cold
the gaseous oxygen condenses giving you
that nice white fog that's normal for
this point in the count token start up
if TS computer click launch director is
announced we're inside of the minute we
are in startup on the flight computers
we are also beginning the pressurized
stage 1 and stage 2 for launch mission
directors go for launch we've heard the
final call-outs mission director launch
director or go for launch
so at t-minus 30 seconds coming up all
systems are go for launch of falcon 9
with gpknives basic it's beautiful
number 3
t-minus 15 seconds and nine eight seven
six five four three two one zero
ignition the stop go Falcon girl GPS
t plus 40 seconds we've heard call-outs
and now we're entering the throttle
market we're powering on the Merlin
engines to relieve the acceleration as
we get ready for the period of maximum
dynamic pressure we're in the throttle
bucket now we're beginning to power back
up
we hear the call-out exiting throttle
bucket the nine Merlin 1b end you're not
going back to full power and we are now
supersonic max-q guidance all engineer
calls out max Q the period of maximum
dynamic pressure or Q on the vehicle
from this point forward although we go
faster and faster the thinner atmosphere
will put less loads on the airframe of
the rocket coming up next is chilling of
the upper stage engine we've got a good
trajectory turn back initial it started
we've begun the chilling of the upper
stage engine power on the merlin 1d
engines looks good
avionics reports everything is nominal
we're at two plus two minutes into
flight next major activity in half a
minute shutdown of the nine Merlin
engines seperate the first and second
stage and ignite the second stage engine
to carry GPS and the second stage into
the first of two orbits today this one
will be the initial parking orbit
Falcon I'm preparing for Miko and Miko
stage separation confirmed
and we've confirmed ignition of the
second stage engine after a good stage 1
stage 2 sup you could see briefly the
Falcon 9 first stage in the background
both vehicles are following nominal
trajectories call out that both vehicles
are following the planned trajectory
first stage can continuing to coast to
Apogee where it will then slowly turn
around and to send back to the drone
ship for landing in the Atlantic Ocean
the second stage engine beginning the
long burn to get it into the parking
orbit acquisition of signal Maryland
coming up fairing deploy waiting to see
the camera switch forward fairing
separation control and we've got fairing
separation the two halves of the Falcon
9 fairing separating the pneumatic
system unlatching the locks that hold it
together and then the pneumatic pusher
separating the two halves is the fairing
falls away from the vehicle we can see
on the left side of the screen the grid
fins the large titanium castings that
are mounted to the first stage have
deployed they'll be used later as we
come back into the atmosphere for
precision guidance of the first stage to
land on the drone ship on the right hand
side we see the second stages are
continuing to burn it's at full power
everything's looking good with the
trajectory so it just passed t+ four
minutes into flight everything is go on
the flight of Falcon 9 with GPS three
space vehicle number three
t+ 4 minutes and 25 seconds into flight
we're currently in the first of two
planned Merlin vacuum engine burns
currently looking at the data the second
stage engine burn is nominal on your
left-hand screen you can see the first
stage as it's performing that
reorientation that Johnna I talked about
the grid fins are deployed and you're
seeing some some thruster plumes there
from the attitude control system that
are getting it ready so that the nine
merlin 1d engines are pointed towards
the atmosphere as it re-enters into
Earth's atmosphere beautiful views of
the planet beneath both the first stage
and the second stage second stage is
continuing into its burn we're expecting
this burns in 15 seconds and entry burn
will actually begin on the first stage
and that just about a minute from now
the end during the entry burn will
ignite three of the merlin 1d engines on
the the first stage that'll give us way
down the stage as it ends up pre
entering the Earth's atmosphere and
reduce the aerodynamic loads as it
starts to bite into the thicker parts of
the the air around our planet you can
see the merlin vacuum engine on your
right-hand screen the nozzle extension
there growing red hot that's expected
we're really we have such a long nozzle
extension on there to try to get the
most most performance out of the
pressure coming out of the thrust
chamber on the second stage engine so
coming up here in about 15 seconds is
entry burn watch that on your left-hand
screen that'll ignite three of the
merlin 1d engines while second stage
continues to burn towards that
elliptical orbit with GPS vehicle
onboard Stage one FTS is saved
Stage one every bird has started their
successful ignition of the three Merlin
Wendy engines on the first stage we're
expecting this burn to last just about
30 seconds
Stage one etchebarren shut down he says
you see some bursts they're successful
shut down of the the engine and some
attitude control bursts just to get that
orientation right now once we get into
the thicker parts of the atmosphere
where those grid fins have some
aerodynamic control Authority they will
do most of the guiding to take the first
stage towards our drone ship name just
read the instructions which is about 350
nautical miles off the east coast of
Florida
the coming up at about 50 seconds from
now we'll have two events happening
about the same time the first stage will
ignite it's single center merlin 1d
engine for landing burn at the same time
the second stage will it will perform
secondary engine based on guidance or
Seco number one all those two things
occur about 25 seconds later the first
stage will hopefully touchdown on our
drone ship in between they're deploying
its landing legs so we'll watch for that
on your left-hand screen h2 FPS is saved
church it Kos Stage one landing bird is
starting mission of that center Merlin
engine on the first stage so you go on
successful confirmation of shutdown of
the Merlin vacuum engine the guidance
engineer is evaluating the orbit of the
second stage now nominal parking orbit
nominal parking orbital exactly boy here
landing like deployment looks like right
down the center and every operators
moving to see other stage excellently so
that's a you know we first flew falcon 9
10 years ago actually this month since
then it's completed 88 missions now the
most flown operational rocket in the
United States this mission completed its
first landing and hopefully we'll have
many more to come
the vehicle is is now we're actually
going to enter into our our
Coast phase now that we know that the
second stage is in a successful parking
orbit that Coast phase will last about
54 minutes and we'll end with second
stage relight at about t plus one hour
and three minutes we're gonna come back
shortly before that cover the the second
engine start number two now as we had
mentioned earlier today's mission is
dedicated by the space force to the
memory of Colonel Thomas Falzarano
commander of the 21st Space Wing at
Peterson Air Force Base in Colorado as a
leader of the Air Force's fifth largest
wing he commanded a workforce of
approximately 4,300 space professionals
worldwide well now hear from general
Raymond and a number of Colonel
Falzarano x' colleagues in the airforce
and space force about the impact he had
on all those he worked with I can think
of no better way to honor Colonel Tom
Falzarano and his family and with
today's launch of our third GPS three
satellite from Cape Canaveral as a
former commander of the 45th Operations
Group Tom not only understood the
critical importance of our launch
capabilities here on the eastern range
but he dedicated his entire military
career to ensure our nation's space
capabilities like GPS continue to fuel
our modern way of life and a lot of way
award Tom was an incredible officer
leader father and friend who made a
difference he was in his prime as he led
the 21st Space Wing at Peterson Air
Force Base at such a critical point in
our nation's history before that he
served as my senior executive officer
who worked tirelessly behind the scenes
and put in long hours as we established
the United States Space Command our
nation's 11th combatant command and the
United States space Force our newest
branch of the armed services also signal
Maryland I kind of made a difference in
the lives of his teammates and those he
led he will always be remembered for
caring for his people while taking care
of the mission
Tom had that unique gift of connecting
with everyone he came in contact with he
always had a smile and a word of
encouragement no matter how demanding
the situation was Tom made a difference
in the lives of his family no one loved
family more than he did and in fact Tom
made us all feel like
we were part of his family as we watched
today's Falcon 9 soar high into space
let Tom's legacy be a reminder for all
of us to make a difference every single
day and how our greatest legacy is found
in the relationships and the investments
we make and the people around us my
sincere thanks to SpaceX the 45th Space
Wing and the entire launch team for
honoring dumplings nobody knew how much
the United States and our international
allies rely on space capabilities every
minute of every day more than Colonel
Tom Falzarano Tom took his mission
responsibilities very seriously but he
was passionate about developing and
taking care of the people under his
command although we lost him well before
his time his outstanding legacy will
live on through the air and space
professionals he led and mentored during
his 26-year career for Tom's family and
in honor of his memory on behalf of the
6,000 professionals of the space and
missile system Center we will continue
to protect and defend the global Commons
of space and continue to mentor our
people which he so clearly cherished
today's launch is dedicated to a warrior
a husband a father a friend an American
hero and a man whose example and
leadership will continue to influence
our air and space force well into the
future we're dedicating today's launch
to Colonel Thomas Falzarano who was the
commander of the US base forces 21st
Space Wing when he tragically passed
away a few weeks ago in a way dedicating
this gps 3 launch to tom is wholly
appropriate as this next generation
satellite provides navigational guidance
to the nation and the world so did Tom
provide lasting guidance and inspiration
to all those he led and served with it
has been our great privilege to have
known and served with Tom Falzarano and
we are proud to dedicate this launch to
him
Colonel Falzarano was a strong steady
leader who was an instant friend
everyone he led he bought lasting
connections everywhere he went and he
cared in Tennessee about everyone here
at the 21st base plane we miss him every
day but we are honoring him and continue
our mission strengthening preparedness
always Croma Falzarano led us by example
to give of ourselves completely and
compassionately he taught us what it is
to be built to last to assure what we
build today will outlive us and last for
those who come after us as we reach
again to the Stars let us strive even
height is only fitting this launch today
be dedicated to Colonel Tom Falzarano a
great American hero on behalf of the
50th Space Wing and the men and women
with Schriever Air Force Base thank you
for your service thank you for your
sacrifice and most importantly thank you
for a partnership over the course of the
last year Colonel foster on O teammate
leader wingman guide much like the GPS
you'll get people to where they ought to
be proud to have served with you Colonel
Tom Falzarano was a true friend of the
30th Space Wing and a personal friend of
mine I've known Tom for over 20 years
when he and I were captains together at
the 5/64 missile squadron and Great
Falls Montana Tom is a kind of person
who would do whatever he could to help
another airmen he looked out for the
folks that he led and he looked out for
his peers and it was my privilege for
the time that we were serving as Wing
Commanders together to serve next to him
chief
sir I had the pleasure of working with
Colonel father ah no as a teammate in
Air Force Base Command headquarters
consummate professional consummate
leader you miss me I miss you Tom it is
so fitting that we as an aerospace force
remember Colonel Tom Falzarano with this
GPS launch Tom spent a lot of time in
Florida and in particular as the 45th
Operations Group commander he sat on
crew for many of our nation's most
important launches tom was truly a
people person who loved his Airmen and
enjoyed hearing their stories he was
caring and kind to everyone he met and
always found time to brag about his
family to Stacey the children it is our
honor to represent the 14,000 men and
women of team Buckley and honor Tom for
his leadership and service to this
nation for many of us who personally
knew him will light a cigar in his honor
after a successful launch here's a toast
it's my pleasure along with other
leaders of the United States space force
to honor the life of Colonel Tom
Falzarano during the SpaceX Falcon 9
launch at the next GPS satellite Colonel
Falzarano is a former commander of the
45th Operations Group and his legacy is
felt throughout the eastern range we
have a saving in the 45th Space Wing
once a shark always a shark and the
Sharks of the wing are so sad to hear of
the passing of Colonel Falzarano we'd
also like to pass on our condolences
until Stacy and the children that our
thoughts and prayers are with them falsy
I just want to say thank you for your
many years of friendship to me
personally and to your many years of
service to the United States in the
United States space force he left us too
young you are and will continue to be
missed
thank you
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
muscle signal [ __ ] delay expected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
muscle signal okay as expected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
excellent
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
muscle signal Diego Garcia's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a OS has me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and beckoned and children
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the webcast of the
falcon 9 mission carrying gps 3 space
vehicle number 3 for the u.s. space
force now if you're just joining us we
have a smooth liftoff at 4:10 p.m.
Eastern Time
followed by separation of the first and
second stages we then had a successful
burn at a second stage Merlin vacuum
engine that placed us in the desired
parking orbit you can see on the screen
we're currently 422 kilometers up we're
passing south of Australia right now our
next major event coming up in just 30
seconds is the second start of the upper
stage engine called SES 2 currently from
the orbit graphic we are receiving data
through our ground station in Tasmania
second stage is firing shuttling pulses
using cold gas make sure propellants are
at the top of the inlets of the pump
ready to light that engine and we've got
video of the upper stage engine and
we've got startup confirmation
propulsion confirms we are up on power
on the in vac D engine now the second
stage will burn for 44 seconds and it's
going to add over 2,000 meters per
second to the speed of Falcon 9 before
we shut it down for the second time now
this shutdown event might be called out
as C co2 now this burn that we are in
right now will place the GPS 3 space
vehicle into the required orbit prior to
separating it from Falcon 9
views coming to you from two cameras on
the bottom of the second stage as we
switch back and forth so that we can see
both sides of the engine
we've got shut down waiting for order
confirmation nominal insertion orbit a
nose kind of fade in the background but
if you heard it we have confirmation
that the second stage is in the good
orbit this is the one we needed to get
to to place the GPS three satellite into
its transfer we're now going ahead into
a second Coast phase with the GPS
satellites still attached to the second
stage now the plan is to deploy the GPS
satellite in about 24 minutes now this
wait period is caused by a couple of
requirements first the second stage
begins a slow spin that will provide
stability to the GPS satellite when it
separates so gives it a slow spin second
we also have to wait until the GPS
satellite itself is in view of two Air
Force ground stations one in Hawaii and
one in California so those steps will be
met at two plus one hour and 29 minutes
and that is when the separation of GPS
from stage two is planned so I'm gonna
pause commentary now during this coast
but we will come back for separation in
about 23 minutes at G+ one hour
28 minutes and 30 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
also signal Tasmania
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
acquisition signal white
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
acquisition signal Vandenberg
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
acquisition is signal South Texas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our launch coverage of
the GPS three space vehicle number three
mission for the United States space
force now if you're just joining us we
had an on-time launch at 4:10 p.m.
Eastern Time
followed by successful ascent stage
separation and two second stage engine
burns on your screen is a view of the
GPS satellite atop Falcon 9 now one note
earlier I had mentioned that today was
our 88th successful launch it's actually
our 87th successful launch today so
coming up in just about 15 seconds from
now is our last major milestone and
that's deployment of the GPS three
satellite from the second stage
separation good purple and successful
confirmation of the spacecraft
continuing on to perform its mission
from here the satellite will undergo
some activation checks and perform burns
to Ray's into a circular orbit about
20,000 200 kilometers above the Earth's
surface and with that that's actually
going to complete our primary mission
now another note if you are watching our
webcast earlier we accomplish another
recovery objective today and that is
successful securing of both the fairing
halves that we jettisoned early on in
the mission so we'll have those for use
on a future mission and that's gonna
bring our webcast coverage to a close
great view looking at the GPS satellite
moving away from the Falcon 9 second
stage we want to thank the United States
space force for entrusting us with
today's GPS three space vehicle three
mission and we also want to thank the
satellite manufacturer Lockheed Martin
SpaceX is one of two certified providers
for national security space launch
missions and we're proud to be able to
offer reliable cost-effective launch
services to the u.s. space force we look
forward to the additional GPS missions
we will be supporting in the
future all I want to give out a special
thanks to the 45th Space Wing for the
range support out of the eastern range
today and finally with this last view
watching GPS three satellite number
three drifting away in the distance we
want to thank all of you our viewers for
tuning in and have a good day
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]